it's great to welcome to the program
today nicholas carr who's the author of
several books on technology
and culture including the pulitzer prize
finalists the shallows what the internet
is doing to our brains
uh so great to have you on i really
appreciate your time
thanks very much dave it's my pleasure
so to start with
um i think there's probably a lot of
people in my audience who generally have
the sense that
uh maybe over the last many years it's
become a little more difficult to do
sort of deeper deeper learning focusing
on one task for an extended period of
time there's some vague notion that
maybe there's something about social
media and 140 character posts that may
be
sort of retraining our brain to some
extent but how do you
generally characterize the way that the
modern internet and and technology
have changed the way that that we mostly
do our thinking
i i think human beings
have trouble concentrating have trouble
screening out distractions
in general were very distractible
and you really do have to practice that
and train yourself to concentrate and
focus and i think what the internet does
in general and certainly social media in
particular
is it doesn't give us either the
opportunity or the encouragement
to train ourselves and
and uh practice
skills of attentiveness because it just
floods us with with information
information that's interesting to us
and grabs our attention but in little
chunks and so my argument is
that essentially what we pay to get this
abundance of fast flowing
information is our ability to
concentrate we can't tap into those
deeper
uh more attentive ways of thinking is
there something that's adaptive from an
evolutionary standpoint
about being easily distracted in the
sense of
you're building a fire but there's a
threat off in the distance and so your
mind goes to that
shiny object or moving object or
something along those lines
i think i think that's exactly it you
know you can
you can understand how in the distant
past
in order to stay alive in order to
survive you needed to know everything
that was
going on around you particularly
anything new which might be a threat or
might be a
opportunity to eat or or whatever so our
the way our brains work is that we're
rewarded
with dopamine in other ways little
pleasure producing chemicals
to gather information and i think it's
exactly that that this is an
evolutionary
instinct that unfortunately we bring
over into this new digital environment
where there's
no end to new bits of information to
grab
and briefly hold our attention one thing
i've read and heard from
some folks is the idea that uh there was
a time in human history not that long
ago really
where there would be a big debate over
a fact because we did not have facts so
readily accessible on
our phones and that i mean this is a
very sort of utopian outlook
now that the facts don't need to be
argued about we just find them
we can devote more time thanks to the
internet and the ready availability of
facts to thinking about the implications
of those facts or the future of humanity
how we should interpret that information
or whatever the case may be
it feels intuitively like that's not
what's going on but what do you think
about that idea anyway
i think you know i think it does go on
sometimes oh really okay there are
there are good uses of the internet and
and not so good
there are a couple of problems with that
that we've learned
one is that actually
having a super abundance of information
available means
anybody can find support for any kind of
belief even though
even if it's totally wrong so the idea
that we'd all
share this base of facts turns out not
to be right human nature
gets in the way and then the other
problem with that is i think when you're
distracted all the time when you're
constantly taking in information
you don't have time in your own mind to
make connections and associations
between all the different pieces of
information around you
and it's those associations and
connections that are required
to give you the bigger context to fit
new information into and that broadens
your thinking deepens your thinking so
uh so yeah we can google all sorts of
stuff on our phones or on our computers
but we're losing our ability to fit new
information
into a bigger context and as a result
we're just kind of turning into
i would argue information gatherers that
don't necessarily have an ability to
engage in a deeper conversation with one
another or in a deeper train of thought
within ourselves there's some
interesting articles i'm reminded of
about
this idea of the political hobbyist
which seems very much related to what
you're talking about which is
given so much free access to information
about what's taking place in the world
politically comments from elected
officials
a lot of of data so to speak um
there's arguably a less effective
political activist that comes out of it
because they
are just consuming information sort of
as you're pointing out and not actually
taking that information and doing
something with it to
politic political differences aside try
to influence
sort of their community and their
surroundings is is that sort of the idea
of what you're saying when you talk
about information overload which may not
be particularly useful
yeah that's that's definitely part of it
i mean what we know about
people is that if you give them an
unlimited amount of information they'll
go out
and cherry-pick the information that
reinforces their existing biases
whether those biases are based on fact
or or
fantasy or fiction or whatever and so
what happens our hope
when we you know when we started out
with the net with the web
was that we'd have such a broad array of
information that people would
would go out and sample different
opinions different points of view
as you say become better able to hear
other
other people and influence them or be
influenced by them
but what we found is that that rarely
happens unfortunately
what what what does happen is we all go
out in our little
bubbles in in in gather the information
that supports our existing biases which
ends up making those biases even
stronger
then we find a lot of people that share
those biases and in that
has a lot to do with the polarization uh
we see today politically and socially
and an inability to talk uh beyond
the group of people that that shares our
point of view to use this sort of
economic
term there's arguably also a diminishing
marginal utility to information
for decision making purposes in the
sense of you know if you're buying a car
as an example that first information
that you you obtain about you know you
probably have a budget right so the
price of cars is very important
do you need a two or four-door car or a
sedan or an suv
over time the additional information
seems to be less and less useful to
actually
getting to a decision right when you get
to what are the spark plugs
what's the the life of the of the led
bulbs or whatever and maybe that's also
an idea to consider here
yeah i i think i think you're definitely
on to something and i hadn't really
considered that but
you know and what happens i i think then
is one of two things either you become
so obsessed by the details
that you kind of uh you
you spend all your time gathering more
and more less and
less valuable information and it
prevents you from actually
acting because you you suffer
information paralysis
and then the other thing is the digger
the deeper you dig if we're talking
about political speech
the more reasons you find to
to put other people at a distance the
more
points of difference you start to
uncover even if they're
trivial points they they loom large as
you gather the
uh keep gathering more and more
information without without necessarily
as i said fitting that information and
understanding that information as a part
of a
bigger broader context yeah that's
something i've thought of in thinking
about for example like the political
divisions within the left
where sure you have some on the left who
are
almost moderate republicans as an
example
and you have some on the left who are
truly socialists but
really there's probably you know pick a
number 85 90 i don't know what it would
be
but there's a lot of overlap about sort
of what the majority of those who
consider themselves on the mainstream
american political left would want and
yet when you look at the discourse on
places like twitter and others
it seems overwhelmingly focused on the
the relatively small differences
yeah in you know in some ways that's
nothing new people
people have been you know subdividing um
themselves even within
even when they share a broad
understanding for a long time but i do
think
uh the internet accelerates or
exaggerates that already common
occurrence it
it it provides not only all sorts of
ways to find new points of distinction
but to to find ever narrower groups that
share your precise
um interest in your in your precise
views and as soon as you
have that group formation then even
other groups who share a lot of your
views seem like
outsiders seem like the enemy and and i
do think that's part of
uh the fragmentation we see even within
uh within groups groups of people who
you would think
would focus on their points of agreement
to go back where we started about
the effect of the internet on our brains
and deep thinking etc
when i've interviewed i interviewed cal
newport previously and read some of his
books and
he at least to some degree believes that
these are issues of sort of training and
thinking of the brain like a muscle and
that if you condition the brain to you
know you really you close a room and you
just
read 30 straight minutes that you're
building up a muscle essentially and
that this helps to push back against the
instincts that may be pushed on us by
sort of the status quo of western
technology and the internet
is your take that the solution is a
systemic one that it's at the individual
level
absent one it has to be the other or
what's your thought on that
i certainly think it's i certainly think
at this point
we've created a set of social norms and
social expectations
that that essentially tell us we should
always be online always monitoring new
information always sending out or
receiving messages
you get that from employers you get that
from schools you get that certainly from
your friends from your
relations so i think it's a systemic
issue at this point
and that doesn't that doesn't mean
there's not an individual component and
i think
cal newport's analogy to building you
know
building muscle is is the right one and
what we know about neuroplasticity
plasticity these days the brain's
malleability
is that you really do have to exercise
ways of thinking if you want to retain
them
otherwise they're going to weaken over
time and and ultimately disappear
and i think as individuals for a long
time now we've been training ourselves
to gather information very very quickly
to to
pull in uh bits of data and lots of
overlapping forms and
we're getting good at that but we have
starved ourselves in effect or not
exercised the ability to pay attention
which is hard for us to do as
i said so i think i think if we want to
change
you certainly have to pay attention to
individual habits but we also have to
recognize that society
is sending these very powerful messages
that tell all of us
stay online uh gather as much
information as you can
and don't turn off the flow of
information
in in practice the more attentive or
contemplative
uh ways of thinking that that are
possible for your mind but are
don't come naturally to us we've been
speaking with nicholas carr and we're
going to go to a break on the podcast tv
and radio show you can find our full
conversation which will continue on the
youtube channel
when it comes to something like in the
math space where
even when i was in high school graphing
calculators became a sort of acceptable
part of a lot of math classes where the
expectation was no longer that you
needed to
remember everything you just needed to
understand the concepts and know
what tools to use in order to arrive at
the answers
that has gone up exponentially with the
advent
essentially of google and and of
smartphone technology
are you able to are there examples of
where
that has been really good getting off of
rote memorization
and then maybe counter examples where it
has not been quite so good
well i think the calculator is still uh
a good example because it shows us both
the good and the bad ways to use it
and what what i think schools found is
that
if students are allowed to master
the the ma arithmetic or mathematic
mathematical concepts if they master it
before they turn
to the calculator to automate it then
they can keep
building their skill levels because any
any complex skill you have to master the
basic levels and then
rise to the next one and so forth but if
you just give students
a calculator and say here you don't have
to you don't have to learn
this process uh you don't have to learn
this rule or whatever
then they never build the base from
which to move up and i think
in when when you look at automation in
general whether it's flying
planes or or doctors learning how to
diagnose
diseases and stuff you see the same
thing play over if you allow
people to to attain mastery of a skill
before you automate that skill then the
technology can be very free
because as you say it relieves you of
the simple
time to do these what are now routine
but if you
simply tell people oh you don't have to
learn that because the
software will do it for you then
actually i think you limit
their expertise and limit their talent
one of the other things i wanted to talk
about was the
the book as a sort of format and and an
idea
it's interesting that newspapers have
struggled dramatically over the years
and they've in many cases essentially
become just online news websites so
it's still the newspaper in a sort of
sense but it's also something
very different um you know you can go
back further to like the phonograph or
whatever and we've seen technologies
come come and go
the book has sort of changed in that now
with kindle and being able to instantly
annotate or look up words it's certainly
a different thing
than the the the sort of one-off very
nicely put together books of the 19th
century as an example
that could take months for for a skilled
bookmaker to make it certainly changed
but the idea of the book of two three
four hundred pages
uh of either fiction or well-researched
non-fiction as a way to communicate
information
that hasn't gone away is there what do
you think is special about the book and
do you expect that at some point
that idea of communicating information
may change
i think you're absolutely right that the
book is kind of the one
big exception to forms of media that
have not been
displaced or changed in a radical way by
digitalization
in 10 years ago it really looked like
the book the printed book was going away
if you remember i think the kindle was
first introduced in 2007 or something
by 2010 if you looked at you know the
rise in
ebook sales they were they were doubling
or tripling every year
uh print sales were basically flat but
soon after that
ebooks hit a wall um they they actually
started
sales started to erode so so i think
what we've discovered
is that there is an experience
uh that we enjoy of sitting down with a
book and i think part of that experience
is that
in its physical form the book you can
think of it as both a literal
in a kind of metaphorical shield against
distraction
if you try to read the same text on your
computer screen or on your phone you can
do it
and it's better than nothing but what
you find is
you you immediately have all these other
calls on your attention just
as if you were doing anything else on
your phone or a computer so there's
something
there's something special that it seems
like the
the the content of a book
is very very well suited to the printed
physical form in your ability to sustain
your attention for a long period of time
that's required to read
so i think you know the the death
sentence that was
that seemed to be looming over the
printed book 10 years ago it it hasn't
panned out
and i think you know you could argue
that that printed books are
less and less central to our culture um
compared to
the internet and social media but still
when people want to read they've shown a
distinct continuing preference for the
printed
form of that yeah almost beyond logic
right i mean it's like
i'm buying bookshelves and you know that
this is as you
you know you have a bunch of books
behind you they take up a lot of space
it's increasingly not logical to some
degree
um and yet right as a format it
perseveres
yeah yeah and i think there are other
reasons as well
i mean you know there's books behind me
and
what what you find is there is a tactile
there's something tactile about a
printed book that's really important
you know i can go back and grab one of
those books off off a shelf
and kind of in a kind of an amazing way
if i'm looking for a particular passage
that i read a long time ago
there's something you can find you can
actually find it pretty
quickly because there's some coming back
to the theme of muscle memory
there's some kind of muscle memory that
comes with the when you read a book
in a tactile way you're there's
i don't know what exactly it is but your
sense of touch
your sense of feel becomes wound up
in in the act of reading and there have
even been studies that show
that that translates into better
retention
and better compreh reading comprehension
um
uh studies of students for instance
show that they retain more and they
comprehend more when they read and print
than when they read the same uh content
online
i've seen yeah that's that's uh that's
super interesting we've been speaking
with nicholas carr author of several
books
on technology and culture including the
pulitzer prize finalists the shallows
what the internet is doing to our brains
i so appreciate your time today thank
you thank you
my pleasure